Welcome to Now You See It.
When characters drown in movies, they’re
gone forever. But more than just the character
leaves. They always take something with them.
Maybe they take away fear
A friendship
trust in others
or a desire to go somewhere new.
But what happens when a character starts drowning
and survives?
He’s not gone forever, but instead, he’s
alive. But he isn’t just alive. He’s alive
all over again. He’s supposed to be dead.
When he rises up again, he changes. But change
isn’t the right word. It’s more violent
than change.
He’s reborn.
Let’s look at drowning more symbolically in The Truman Show.
Truman lives on an island, caged from reality. He’s
been conditioned to fear the outside world
after the drowning of his father. Finally,
he sails out of his world and confronts the
next, nearly drowning in the process. It’s
the same pattern we see in baptism: death
and rebirth through the medium of water. Truman
goes in still scared of the outside world
and comes out ready. He died and was born again.
In any drowning scene we see symbolic rebirth
which originates from the Judeo-Christian
sacrament of baptism: a new believer is taken
completely underwater, dies out of his old
self and is reborn in his identity as a follower of Christ.
Using water as death and rebirth
imagery has been used for centuries in literature,
but it has since found its way into film.
Every drowning experience has a different
meaning based on the context. Whoever causes
you to nearly drown is the symbolic enemy, and whoever saves you is your symbolic savior.
This includes drowning yourself and saving yourself. And if you’re unable to save someone else, that
represents losing a part of yourself if that person was close to you.
Baptism imagery is not restricted to violent
drowning. We can see the same death and rebirth,
more subtly, in, say, a shower scene or a
sewage drain followed by a torrential downpour.
While not as apparent, any scene where a character
gets cleansed with water can represent a death
and rebirth for the character.
The shower scene in Psycho has baptism imagery.
Actress Janet Leigh said in her book on the
film: “Marion had decided to go back to Phoenix,
come clean, and take the consequence, so when
she stepped into the bathtub it was as if
she were stepping into the baptismal waters.
The spray beating down on her was purifying
the corruption from her mind, purging the
evil from her soul. She was like a virgin
again, tranquil, at peace.”
In the shower, she’s cleansing herself of
her sins. In her attempt, though, she gets
murdered, and fails in her baptism.
Countless films use water as a way
of showing a deep internal change for a character.
So whenever someone goes underwater, whether
they’re hiding, feeling trapped, getting
super powers, or falling out of an exploding
plane, remember that getting dunked underwater
represents a part of them dying and another
part being born.
Or maybe it’s just a way to get a kiss from
Wendy Peffercorn.